hello welcome to my talk rethinking
software testing for data science
imagine you are working on a data
science project and you get a new
development machine that only has the
operating system installed
you get the raw data for your project
and you get your code
how much time is it going to take you to
reproduce the results that you reported
previously
ignore the time that it takes for your
code to process the data
just take into account the time that it
takes for you to
maybe install dependencies or do any
manual steps in bold and start running
your pipeline
if it takes you more than 5-10 minutes
there's a lot of room
for improvement now take into account
that processing at dataset that has been
modified doesn't count as
reproducibility because your analysis
goes
from your raw data all the way to the
final output
since um we any change that we
introduced to
our project has the potential to break
things we should be testing our code for
reproducibility every time we make a
change
this is not practical because it means
that we have to spend time
checking things every time we introduce
a change and
this idea of testing software is
not new and we should be writing a
different
program that automates this process for
us and this is what software engineers
do every day
they automate the process of testing
software
this talk is about software testing but
from the data science perspective
we are going to introduce the principles
of software testing
we are going to also speak about the
challenges that we face when we
when we want to apply these principles
to data science and how we solve
uh solve these problems we cannot simply
apply the regular procedure
because data science projects have
specific characteristics that we have to
take into account
we're also going to speak about some
debugging strategies how do we go about
fixing problems in our projects and make
sure that these books don't come up
again
and we're also going to mention some
tools and resources so that you can
start applying these principles into
your projects with open source
options what's the standard software
testing procedure
it goes like this a programmer
introduces a small set of changes to a
project then they save the changes
and if you are using a version control
system like it
this means creating a new commit then
your tests are executed
you wait for the results to come back
and if the changes
didn't break anything it means success
if any of the tests break
didn't pass it fails
and the idea is that if all your tests
pass you can move on and work on
something else
if your tests um didn't pass then you
have to revisit your changes fix them
and try again
which are the benefits of ultimate
testing the first thing is that we can
quickly be notified when we break things
and that's great because we make sure
that as we make changes we are
always keeping things um working well
we since we are introducing small
changes we can also pinpoint errors to
assist specific lines of code it's much
easier to find an error in 20 lines of
code
than 200 lines and overall this
speeds up the development cycle because
even though we are writing another
program to test our
original program it allows us to repeat
this site
call very quickly about introducing
changes testing
then checking for results one important
thing to keep in mind is that
for testing to be effective results have
to come back quickly because we have to
wait
for the tests to be done to make a
decision of
continuing or revisiting our changes
now data science has some challenges
when we want to apply these principles
and this is very important because we
cannot simply apply the standard
procedure that i explained before
the first challenge is coming up with
good test cases
when we are testing software we want to
test with representative inputs of
things that
we want our code to cover for example if
we are testing a traditional
piece of software maybe an e-commerce
website we may have a function that
locks in users
well we can come up with some test cases
like what happens if i pass a wrong
combination of user and password
these kinds of things come up naturally
but in data science we usually have
functions like get data clean data
transform data it's not so easy to come
up with good test cases for these
types of transformations these types of
functions the second challenge is a
structure since our analysis has a
predefined order
we get the data then we clean it then we
transform and we have to do it in that
order we have to take that into account
when we want to test a software that has
this kind of structure
the other challenge is speed if we are
dealing with big data sets
our pipeline may take a lot of time to
run but even with small data if we are
using complex
complex algorithms the processing time
might be long enough
that we cannot run our pipeline every
time we
introduce a change and finally changing
data
even if we follow all these
recommendations if the data that we are
using as input changes this has the
potential to break
our code so we have to keep that in mind
let's speak about
the first challenge testing data
transformations
the first question that we should ask
ourselves when we are testing a piece of
software is what can go wrong
imagine we are working with user
streaming data people
listening to songs and we have three
columns the user id the timestamp and
the song genre
as we start doing some exploratory
analysis we
start to build a picture of how the data
looks like and what are the properties
maybe we were assuming initially that we
always have a timestamp and then we find
that sometimes the timestamp is missing
or we may be assuming that the song
genre is always a rock pop or jazz and
then we find some rows and have unknown
it's not a missing value it's actually
the string onc node but we cannot spend
all our time
doing exploratory analysis at some point
we have to move and start doing other
things
the important idea is that all these
expectations that we have about the data
we should make them explicit
and when i say explicit i mean writing
things writing a piece of code that
checks those expectations
for example if we are assuming that we
should always have a user id
because that that's implicit in our code
well let's make that expectation uh
explicit before we run that piece of
code
so we write this test that checks that
we always have a user id
if our code is assuming that we only
have rock pop and jazz
let's make that uh that explicit and
test that
what goes into that piece of code only
has those values that it
doesn't in our case that it doesn't have
the unknown value
and this this same idea applies if you
are using sql
even if you your project is written as
written in python you may be interacting
with a database
and your data exists in a database it's
going to be much faster just to run
these things directly in sql
so you can also apply these ideas in
different languages
now i i spoke about testing our
expectations about the data
but we are also writing code and we
should make sure that our code
works as expected so this is a different
type of testing which is called unit
testing
and this scenario happens in our
pipeline assuming we have our day
expectations as
tests this happens when data is expected
but the output from our code
is incorrect the idea here is that if we
have a let's say we have a function that
cleans uh
some some data we should break down this
big function that performs several
operations
into smaller functions that have really
concrete behaviors so that we can come
up with test cases easily
uh and the idea is that
we go from something that is kind of
abstract like and like
has a lot of things going on to
something that is very specific
and we isolate a lot of things and this
makes
testing easier and it's also important
to think in terms of what makes a good
unit test
you are going to be testing cases that
are representative of what you
are going to see when you analyze the
data and it's really easy to fall into
this trap
where you call unit cases that don't
make much sense so i'm gonna give an
example of
how you can think about unit testing
let's imagine we have a function
inside our clean songs
function we have another function that
does a
count operation so it's going to count
the number of songs for every genre for
each user
and this function is called count song
genres
and the piece of code that you see on
the right is
written using the pi test library which
is a library that i highly recommend for
writing unit tests so we have two tests
here
as we can see in the code snippet we
have the complete case this is a user
with id number one
and this person has listened to a rock
song a pop song and a jazz
song so the output is gonna be uh three
columns
rock pop and jazz and the values are
going to be one one one
now this is uh a good scenario from
someone who's been listening to these
three genres
now it may happen that someone doesn't
listen to the three genres
at all but we should still be counting
correctly
so let's imagine we have another user id
user ideas number two but this person
only likes rock and pop
well we expect to see
the just column as output so that's
something that we should be testing
and as you can see in the body of the
function what we are doing is we are
calling the function with those two
input cases
and we are making sure that we have the
right
set of columns now this is a very simple
test and you could test
other things such as the actual values
in the column but this is the important
idea that you should be testing for
concrete things
and also think in terms of uh scenarios
where
that you should be covering
so now let's speak about a recipe for
writing data transformations and
this is a recipe that if you follow step
by step is going to help you to write
more robust data transformations
let's imagine we have we are working on
the counseling genres function
the first thing even if before we called
anything we just write the name of the
function
we write the docs string and a docstring
is just a string that
goes right below the name of the
function
and that explains our purpose for for
this piece of code it's
basically a justification for why do we
have this function
and it's this is very important not only
for other people but also for you
because uh like one or two weeks from
now we are going to forget why you have
that piece of code there
so that's step number one step number
two is to think
what am i expecting about the data what
am i expecting in terms of the input for
this function and we should be writing
the data tests the expectation tests
the third step is to think what
scenarios
should my code cover which are the cases
where the
the data is expected and i should be
operating and applying some
transformations
those are uh that's kind of the
reasoning that you should follow for
thinking
for good unit test cases and finally
you code your function you run your
tests
and keep going until all your tests pass
and that's how you you make sure that
your implementation is correct
at least uh by taking into account how
many scenarios you tested with your
integration test and your unit tests
let's speak about the second challenge
data pipeline
structure our data analysis
goes through several stations that have
a predefined order
and this has a really important
implication when we are testing
code because it means that any error
that happens in
let's see this pipeline we have two
branches for analyzing the user's data
and the generals
let's imagine we are working with the
user's data if we get the data
and something bad happens there all
those errors are going to propagate
to all the downstream tasks in this case
all these errors are going to propagate
to clean users
and potentially even to the code that
trains the model
so when we are doing testing it's very
important that we account for this
fact so now let's revisit
our idea of data expectations and data
testing and turn this into
another idea a very similar idea which
is integration testing
it's the same thing we are going to make
explicit our expectations about the data
but now we are saying how and where
we are going to make these tests and the
idea is very simple
you have your pipeline and then right
after you run
your task for example get users you test
you run your data expectations so for
every task in your pipeline
you are going to have one function the
function that runs the actual code and
then another function the function that
tests
the output and so so that you can
explicitly test
your expectations about data
now if you are analyzing a big data set
or any of these tasks
takes a lot of time to run running your
integration testing
is going to take a lot of time because
that implies running your pipeline from
start to finish
and as i mentioned before speed is very
important so how do we
go about that how do we go about speed
that is actually very simple
since your pipeline operates in many
batches of data
and applies the same transformations too
many rows at once
we can simply pass a sample and if we if
we pass a smaller amount of data
the pipeline is going to process it in a
much faster so this is a really simple
idea
but you it implies some work from you
because it means that you have to code
your pipeline as a structural chain of
uh
chain of transformations and you have to
make sure that your data expectation
tests
run right after every task and there are
a few
uh a few tools that you can use
they are called workflow management
tools that you can use to turn your code
into a pipeline
my recommendation is to use plumber
which is a library that i've developed
and it it applies this idea and it
allows you to write pipelines very
quickly so that's what you see
on the left side this is one example of
how you can develop a pipeline as you
can see it's just a simple
uh jaml file where you say
uh the source is gonna be this script
for get users and when this task is done
i wanna run
this function which is defined in
another file and i'm going to pass one
parameter to this function which is
going to be sample and this is going to
allow me to run the entire thing
with the sample and we just repeat the
same thing for all the tasks that we
have we say
where's the source code what function we
want to execute when the task finishes
and in this way we can quickly switch
sampling on and off
so that we when we want to run our
integration testing quickly we just say
run the pipeline with sampling on and
when we want to see
the actual output with the full data set
we just turn the sampling off
there are a few other options and things
that you can do to speed up your
integration testing even more one
great idea is to do incremental builds
let's say for example that you
in this pipeline you modify clean users
if you modify clean users
you don't have to run get users again
you also don't have to run get generous
or clean generous
you only have to run clean users and
train models so running your integration
testing is much faster because you are
running
less fewer tasks
the second idea is to run tasks in
parallel uh
we can see in this pipeline we have two
branches that are independent and they
meet until you train a model so you can
run these tasks at the same time and you
can
save a lot of time by doing this and all
and these ideas are already implemented
in bloomberg so
it's very easy for you to get
integration testing
to speed up really fast
now let's speak about the last challenge
which is data changes
even if you are doing all these testing
and all these things and you are taking
proper care
of all these ideas if
the data that you are consuming changes
your pipeline is probably going to break
so
we have to think about how do we
approach this problem well the first
practical thing to notice is that
covering
all possible input cases is unrealistic
we are not going to cover all possible
uh
data input input cases because we simply
don't have enough time
we cannot just spend all our time
testing and i'm not doing the actual
work which is the analysis
so that's a very important thing
my recommendation is to focus on writing
data tests
because those are really fast uh
to write you just have you simply have
some ideas about the data
and you said that you write that in code
and it's
one or two lines it's very easy to write
and if the
the data tests don't pass well uh you
just have to
go and revisit your expectations but
this gives you
you are kind of reducing the scope of
your code and saying i only want my code
to work under these conditions
so in this way you have to you are
coding
simpler functions and you are only going
to increase the complexity
if you see something in the data that
requires you to do so
this testing trade-off is very important
to keep in mind
might in one end you want to be
writing a lot of tests so that you uh
can make sure that your data pipeline is
robust
on the other hand you cannot simply keep
testing over and over again
and this also has a important
implications in terms of the nature of
data science
because the the most important thing
when you are working a data science
project is to try a lot of things
ahead of time you don't know if some
pre-processing method is going to work
or not
so a lot of the code that you write is
not going to end up in production and
you are just going to throw it away so
it's not worth your time to test and
test and test things that you are not
going to use but there's a trade-off
right because what happens if you
implement some piece of code that you
that doesn't uh work but it doesn't work
not because of the
actual process but because you don't
implement it correctly
so as you get more experience you are
going to
have more confidence in balance work to
balance this threshold and
it's very important to keep this this
idea in mind
and the final um the final idea is
called reusability
if you have less code there are fewer
things that you have to test
so this is very important and this has
uh
two two different implications the first
one is that you should be using
other packages for example if you are
doing machine learning
don't implement your own model just use
another library like scikit-learn
or keras and also keep in mind that you
should be using
libraries that are maintained because
that's if you are using
libraries that are no longer maintained
that's going to have a whole lot set of
different issues
but the second thing also implies that
you should
reuse not only the code from other
packages but your own code
if you find yourself that you are
writing uh several functions that
perform similar things
it's a good idea to write a single
function that maybe has some parameters
to tweak
how it behaves and in this way you only
have to test a single function
as opposed to testing five functions
that do pretty much the same thing
now um this these are good ideas for
development but when you are going to
take your project
to production uh you have a different
set of concerns that you should be aware
of
the first important thing is that you
should define an unambiguous input
schema definition
and this is really just a few data
expectations at the beginning of your
pipeline because
you are saying if my pipeline is going
to production i'm going to be making new
predictions i should define what my
expectations about the input are
there's no point in running your
pipeline if the input doesn't uh
has it it doesn't have this specific
format when you are going to deploy
it's important that you heavily invest
in unit testing
because you have to cover more use cases
when you are developing you can
spend more time trying out new
experiments and writing data tests
but when you are going to deploy to
production you have to take care that
you cover more cases that
shouldn't raise errors for example and
speaking about errors is very important
that you have good error messages so
that you can
debug things and if something goes wrong
you are quickly able to understand
what's going on
and related to having good error
messages is the idea of vlogging
if you have good logging it's going to
be easier for you to understand what
happened
if something breaks and there's also um
this idea data science products when
they go to production they usually
are deployed either in batch batch
predictions for example you make
predictions for all your users every
month
or as live api api where you would have
a service
uh that can make predictions on demand
for everyone who
wants to get a prediction and for the
first case for the batch case
you are kind of in development mode
right because you don't have that
pressure if
uh you make predictions monthly and
something goes wrong
well you can just delay the predictions
for one or two days and fix things
for a live api the requirements are much
um strict because you have to make sure
that you get a proper response to
whoever is going to consume
the service that you are working on
now let's uh go to debugging strategy
this is very important because
when you find errors you have to follow
a principal the strategy so that you
fix the errors and they don't come up
again
let's speak about fixing crashes what
happens when you run your pipeline and
it crashes
there are three scenarios and
understanding which scenario
uh the case that you are dealing with
falls on
you have to do some detective work the
first case is unexpected data
and this happens when you see that one
of your data tests
crashes and this is actually a good
thing because it means that you
cut something that shouldn't go through
your pipeline that
doesn't uh comply with your data
expectations
then if you find that you are in this
case you either have to relax
your data expectations maybe you have to
revisit the definition of your tests
or leave some data out maybe you keep
that's for you to decide maybe you
decide to keep your tests
as they are but in the previous task you
are going to remove
some data that shouldn't go through your
pipeline
and if you do this just make sure that
you have a comment to explain
why you are leaving some observations
out from processing
the second case is unexpected data
but when the task crashes not the data
expectation
the code in the task
this implies that you have a missing
data test
because the tasks shouldn't crash if
your data is expected
right so the the idea is that you should
be adding
a data test then run your pipeline
make sure that your um pipeline crashes
at that point and then you're back to
case one
uh the third case is incorrect code so
again your task crashes
but it's um it's not it is not computing
what you are expecting it
to do so this means that you have a
missing
unit test so you should add this unit
test
um see it fail see that the current
implementation does not work
then fix it run the test and see that
it passes one important idea that you
should keep in mind is that you should
be fixing
problems in the right place imagine that
you
find your training model procedure is
crashing
and maybe it's some of the
rows for the users that have some issue
which is
causing your training model to crash you
might be tempted to fix
apply this fix in your trained model
code
the first question that you should ask
yourself is who is resp
which task is responsible for this
output and maybe you realize that
this is really something that clean
users should take care of
right so you should shouldn't apply uh
the fixed
wherever you find it because you you
maybe have to fix it in a different
place where
it is more appropriate to apply the
change and this is important for
tasks whose output is used by many other
tasks
if you apply the same the fix
in the root cause in the task that
should be responsible for that piece of
data you only have to apply that patch
that fix
once instead of in every task that uses
that output the other scenario which is
harder to fix
are silent bugs and this usually happens
for example when you train a model
and you realize that it doesn't have
doesn't have the performance that you
were expecting
or you compute some summary statistics
and the numbers don't make sense
so there's nothing crashes it's it's
just that
our results don't make sense so this
indicates a missing
unit or data test and again this is some
detective
work that you have to do to know if it's
one case or the other
and to fix this kind of issues you once
you
find something that doesn't make sense
you should work
backwards to find the same idea right so
who is responsible who should be
responsible for this piece of data
then you are the missing unit or data
test
depending on the case and then you apply
the same logic that we explained before
for fixing crashes so you basically
convert your
silent bug in an actual crash
and then you fix it
now i presented a lot of ideas and this
slide contains really
the most important messages from this
talk and that's what you
what i want you to take away from this
the first
important thing is that testing makes
reproducibility practical
unit tests check concrete expected
behavior in a
unit code in a piece of code
which is usually a single function
integration tests check input output
boundaries
so these are uh the tests that are going
to verify
that the output from some task is a is
an appropriate
input for the next task
you can speed up your integration
testing with sampling
you have to be prepared for data changes
you
should be writing your tests before you
actually write your code
and that you should be fixing box in the
right place
and you should be asking where it is the
best
place to fix this thing who which task
should be responsible
responsible for this this output tools
and resources
these are the tools that i recommend you
to use to start applying these
principles the first one is plumber
which is library that i
mentioned before and i'm developing it
allows you to write data pipelines
easily and it has support for
integration testing
you can also parameterize your pipeline
so so you switch the
sampling parameter on and off you can
you get incremental builds and parallel
execution so you can speed up your
integration testing even more it also
integrates with jupiter which means you
can develop your pipelines in an
interactive way
for your unit tests i recommend you to
use pi test it's a very powerful library
uh spend some time understanding how it
works and you'll be writing very concise
powerful unit tests
in no time finally a tool that i
recently discovered nox
this library allows you to recreate your
virtual environment before you run your
tests and this is uh this is great
making dependence installation part of
your testing procedure because sometimes
we forget to document dependencies we
just do
a pip install but we never uh keep a
record of these things so if you don't
document your dependencies
things may break so if you are
installing your dependencies every time
your test
you you'll know when these things
happened
and finally some resources if you want
to take a look at the slides you can get
them from
there any questions feedback about this
talk or plumber or anything
reach out via twitter i have blog posts
where i explain uh the same ideas that i
talk here and also expand on some other
topics that i didn't cover
and finally have a code example which
you can take a look to see
how all these ideas look in code and i
also set up
this this example to work with
continuous integration
and i want to thank michael snow who
provided very
valuable feedback to improve this
presentation
that's it thanks for watching
you